from calorie counts of portion sizes we
wanted to find the differences between
MREs and ration packs in the US and the
UK this is food
[Music]
Wars a US MRE is manufactured and
packaged by Warick Americal and so Paco
uh and come in one standard pack size UK
MREs or ration packs as we call them are
produced by vesty foods and come in
three portion sizes the standard portion
is this a 24-hour ration pack you can
also get a a smaller version which is a
12-hour Russ pack and our biggest
portion is this this is a 10man
operational pack which contains 10 of
these 24-hour ration packs according to
the defense Logistics agency website a
case of MREs which is 12 Meals weighs
around 22 lb or 9.98 kg so on average
one meal would be roughly
8316 G the approximate weight of one of
these ration packs is 1.75 kg but we're
going to weigh it to see if that's
accurate
so the weight of our 24-hour rationing
pack here in the UK was actually 1.49 kg
this is a bit lower than the promised
1.75 I don't know if you're a soldier in
the field if this is actually a positive
thing because you got less weight to
carry or if you're actually getting
slightly less food than you were
promised in the UK our ration pack menu
number two contains a chili con carne
we're going to compare ours to the
American chili to see who's getting
more I do think I've lost a little bit
in here and if I were eating this
straight out of the packet maybe tearing
the packet open and getting better
access I could probably get that closer
to the 300 mark so here are the contents
of a 24-hour ration pack in the UK in
total we counted 29 edible items as well
as a few extra bits including tissues
sanitary wipes matches and other stuff
like that we counted 11 edible items in
our us ration
pack here are all the military MREs for
the US not available in the UK and here
are all the ration packs in the UK that
you can't find in the US there's
actually very few overlap of specific
meals in US MREs and the UK ration packs
also depending on which M meal you get
uh they contain different combinations
of snacks and sides in both countries
official MREs are not available for sale
directly to Consumers basically when you
get a ration pack in the UK it will come
with a corresponding menu number the
menu number will give you a rough
indication of what you're going to find
inside although there is a bit of
variation so what we've done here is lay
out the breakfast and the main course
options in order of the menus in the UK
we cover able to get hold of menus 1 to
10 all right we got the US MREs I think
we got every menu 1 through 24 we're
going to go through the Entre and the
breakfasts now I want to point out that
for the US MREs not every single one
came with a definitive breakfast and
some of them just had something that was
fruit or fruit related which we assumed
was supposed to be eaten first thing in
the morning now all of these can be
eaten either hot or cold I guess ideally
you'd have them heated up we actually
got sent this flameless heating bag
instructions for use this is either
going to go really well or I'm going to
give myself and the food Wars table some
chemical bands I'm going to do a chili
because we've already got a chili opens
and I kind of know what they taste like
filter line only and then leave that for
10 minutes
oh well it
works I hope I've sealed that well
enough cuz that steamed up very quickly
there so while that does it s I guess
All That Remains is for me to try the
rest of them turn down here remember a
good friend the chili not bad I would
say as average as chili can be I think
honestly I've never been in the military
I haven't done any service but I used to
Camp a lot when I was a kid and I do
remember going on like sometimes two
three week long canoe trips in Canada
couple days in this is like Gourmet you
know what I'm talking about like your
standards change quickly when you're
outside all day it comes with a
cornbread this cornbread muffin is
actually like really good let's try with
that chili so the breakfast that we got
for menu one was pork sausage and beans
in a tomato sauce this is like kind of
an iconic British meal I can't lie it's
kind of good we're starting off strong I
like that next up we have a pindy Chana
Aloo which seems to be like a potato and
chickp cry and then the final option
from menu one in the UK meatballs and
pasta do I have high or low expectations
for meatballs and pasta yeah I mean I
think my fear was that like pasta
doesn't hold up very well when it's kind
of submerged in a sauce and cooked for a
while and I think that's kind of come
true
meates are right there menu number two
is shredded beef and barbecue sauce but
also came with seasoned black beans and
tortillas so I mean I don't know how you
would do this out in the field with no
plates and not a table and then the
beans a military Taco here we go these
beans are Rock Solid the consistency is
a little weird this one is the chicken
and noodles with vegetables and
sauce yeah this this looks like like uh
like a can of like Chunky Soup or chunky
stew before you heat it up this
definitely should be heated up before
and this oh my God this is brutal if you
had this and you couldn't heat it up for
some reason this is very bad the first
potential breakfast the applesauce with
raspberry puree now we're talking
here oh my God that does not taste like
fruit that tastes like pure sugar there
is fruit in it but it tastes more like
like uh fruit flavored soda this will
definitely wake you up in the morning on
to menu too and the breakfast is a
raspberry mule with milk now it says
with milk but there is no liquid in here
so I think what they've done is actually
put powdered milk in here and you add
some water and then hopefully that kind
of turns into something resembling milk
it looks very uh chalky and powdery at
the moment without the water in it it
says to add around 100 Ms of water mix
it and then leave it to stand for a
minute or so but yeah I mean now that's
looking a lot more like musy that's
actually not bad quite impressed by that
there is like like a slightly noticeable
difference between that and real milk
then the mains for menu two obviously
the chili Kong car which we opened for
the portion sizes section not the best
visuals but it's quite hard to make a
nice looking chili anyway so it's more
about the taste it's not spicy pretty
well seasoned and the menu too also has
a rajma masala the longer I leave this
one I think this is the first one that
has actually like a bit of heat to it
but not unpleasant at all just like a
nice a nice warmth there this HS close
to home spaghetti with beef and
sauce oh and it even came with Italian
bread sticks what do we think it's not
meatballs they had meatballs we only
have meat
sauce red sticks they're a bit dry
they're the most driest thing I've ever
eaten these are so dry it's white
chicken chunks oh no it's
just I just canned white
chicken no i' I'd be so
bummed guys is the worst one so we got a
beef taco filling with Santa Fe
rice um not horrible decent seasoning
but yeah I think what's missing for all
these is cheese then we're on to menu
three and we have our first duplicate
item it's another musle for breakfast
now this one I'm intrigued by one of the
main options in menu 3 steak and
vegetables with dumplings a classic
British beef stew is kind of one of my
favorite foods having said that I've
opened this and it looks and smells like
cat food now I've been eating most of
these straight out of the bag because
they've had a kind of texture which
permits that but this one I think we're
going to have to Plate up this uh
apparently is steak and vegetables with
dumplings now I started the section by
saying that all of these can be eaten
hot or cold and I do think that's true I
guess the question is whether or not all
of them should be eaten hot or cold and
I think this one just immediately from
the look of it I think probably needs to
be heated up because we've had our uh
our first wamp wamp moment of the
episode God
that's not good beef strips in a savory
tomato sauce marinara sauce with
meatballs wait so there's no noodles
just sauce and
meatballs oh my goodness look how little
these meatballs are look at these little
guys there's no there has no pasta in
here just the meatballs yeah oo
spaghettio level of meat flavor beef
stew no at least this one has noodles
and this one came with a
breakfast that was grape jelly we're
going to jump ahead slightly to menu
eight because that's where I've taken
our hot main from and the alarm has just
gone off which means it's ready to eat
once it's cooked just tear it along here
and then it's at the perfect height that
you can then just also tear this and eat
the whole thing it's changed the
consistency of this a little bit I think
with the steak and vegetables for
example I think that would change the
consistency a lot whereas this has just
made it like a little bit more runny but
not too bad it was very hot but that's
still really good I think this one I do
prefer heat up actually it brings out a
few more of the flavors a little bit
more depth of flavor to it that's really
good and I'm so impressed with this like
heating pad thing the uh the heating pad
as well as just I guess warmed up Meals
thumbs up for me so far macaroni in a
beef sauce that's good we got noodles
and the chili oh it's terrible it
doesn't taste like anything vegetarian
taco pasta which is a vegetable crumble
with pasta and taco style
sauce is this supposed to be zappel
sauce who doesn't love a little
applesauce again wow super sweet but
sugar not high fructus corn soups that's
a plus and the last item for menu three
is a beef burrito style filling with
rice sadly this does not come with any
tortillas so you can't make an actual
burrito with it it's a little bit more
spice than anything else that I've had
so far the texture of the rice would be
improved by heating this one up cuz the
rice is still like a little bit Al Dente
elbow macaroni and tomato sauce granted
I mean I know I got to heat them up yeah
this one's all right uh mango peach
applesauce liking the applesauce this
would be considered I guess a breakfast
or it's it's fruity so maybe this you
would have first thing in the day oh
yeah oh this is really good next up we
got menu four and we're starting with an
all day breakfast apparently differs
from the sausage and beans because this
contains some omelette as well as some
bacon pieces I think my only criticism
of this is that the sauce that they put
the beans in is like exceptionally sweet
carrying on through menu four we have a
pasta bolog M I have a similar concern
to the meatballs and pasta I think that
is like roughly the color that you want
your bolog sauce to look like I think
when I looked at this one I was
expecting worse again like the vibe I'm
getting particularly from the pasta
dishes is very much like tinned pasta
Vibe like a tinned bolise and the last
menu for item is a chicken curry with
potatoes and rice there's actual like
decent Siz pieces of what I hope is
chicken less flavorful than some of the
other ones I want to try heating some of
these up you do this let you put your M
inside sorry you can't tell R water to
this here we go real exciting stuff here
in the studio while we're moving on so
we got one two three heating up the
staff was able to make this thing work I
was not I don't know why but moving on
we have a cheese tortillini and a tomato
sauce oh yeah look at this I got the
whole the whole tortillini right there
then we're on to menu five and we're
starting off with another musley it's
the third musle we've had in five meals
the variation I think is going to start
to kind of run dry speaking of a lack of
variation meal 5 also has another pasta
bolise the different option for meal 5
is a sweet and sour chicken with rice
good color on it nice uh familiar orange
color there's pineapple in this and
water chestnuts I'm kind of impressed
this is pretty good I'd say this leans
more on the balance of sweet rather than
sweet and sour I think with the water
chestnut and also the kind of like
pineapple chunks there's still some
things in there with bites which I
appreciate creamy spinach fetuccini with
egg noodles spinach and mushroom in a
cream sauce
oh it feels like they're going a
little I don't say overboard cuz I
figured you got have like a variety of
meals but doesn't like a fetuccini with
mushrooms and a cream sauce like after a
long day of hauling stuff around and
soldering and exhausting job and
carrying all the stuff and just being
like ah let's kick back with some
spinach mushrooms and a cream sauce like
the most colorful one so far I don't
feel great I do not feel good next up is
menu six which we've actually covered
all of already starts with an all day
breakfast which I've had then moves on
to a another pasta bones which I've also
had finishes with my old friend steak
vegetables with dumplings which I will
absolutely not be trying again this
should be the Mexican style chicken stew
oh and then they're saying there's
another tear here to remove the M very
smart so you got a second spot to tear
this is really smart second spot to tear
so it's easier just to
grab the M
out all right so the package is hot so
it feels like this is much I kind of
smooshing around a little bit so they
are still flimsy tortillas but looks
like they're Chipotle flavored not as
gelatinous I
guess definitely better heated up yeah I
like this it's pretty good next up is
menu seven which I don't know if this
was deliberate or not but appears to be
like a fully vegetarian menu for
starters we have a vegetarian all day
breakfast I think the main difference is
that they've subbed out the meat
sausages for vegetarian sausages it's
another one that seems to be like mostly
beans it seems very fitting the British
army is powered by baked
beans makes you proud to be British it's
got the same issue as before that the
beans are just like I think too sweet
one of the main course options in menu 7
is the rashma Masala with rice which
I've again also had but one that I have
not had is a vegetable and chickpea
Biryani I like a Biryani for those who
don't know it's just
like various things sometimes me in this
case vegetables cooked down with rice
and a bunch of Indian spices I've had
much better Biryani in the past I'm sure
there are lots of people watching at
home and recoiling in horror at the
thought of this being a Biryani but it's
okay and I think on the whole the
vegetarian menu pretty good moving on we
have the chicken burrito bowl which
comes in a bag and not a bowl sure a lot
of this just like I know we got some
heated up so you can see the difference
when it's not heated up it's just this
weird gel Cube and that comes with what
essentially would be considered a
breakfast I guess Apple pieces and a
spiced sauce so the entree appears to be
a maple flavored pork sausage patty okay
so just one block of
yep ah it is of course just this it's
like a cliff bar but pork not good
really weird it tastes uh surprisingly
Bland a hash brown potato with bacon
pepper and onions ooh no this is the
most cat Foody looking menu eight is
another duplicate one we start with
another all day breakfast then there's
another chili con carne which which I've
actually already heaten up and eaten and
we have another beef burrito style
filling with rice I cooked beef ravioli
once again it like heated the bottom of
it so you still got to kind of still got
to massage it a little bit like this
this side is heated and then this middle
part didn't get heated it also came with
tortillas which is funny this is what
this looks like and it looks gross menu
9 starts with more musy then mes do a
new dish which is sausage casserole this
is another like classic British dish a
sausage casserole slow cooked stewed
sausages with tomato potatoes other
vegetables on the whole the sausages
have actually been like surprisingly
good it might just be because I quite
like those slightly cheap like
prepackaged sausages and then for your
other main course we have another pindy
Chana Aloo this one another hot one oh
it's just it's just going to be a
Patty
oh it has a sauce apparently it's
grilled jalapeno pepper jack flavored
comes with L gr and potato
potatoes more rten potatoes what do you
think of that this looks really rough
Italian sausage with peppers onions in a
marinara sauce yeah okay menu number 21
should be lemon pepper tuna or tuna
chunks in a bag we've just been informed
that this bag exes white chicken chunks
saw before there is a lemon pepper tuna
that we don't have and finally last but
not least we have menu 10 which starts
with an instant porridge the cooking
instructions actually specify that you
need to put boiling water in it leave it
for 3 minutes to soak and then eat it
whereas all the other ones are
technically able to be eaten cold menu
10 has a couple of Ms one of which is
another beef burrito style filling with
rice and our final main course is
Hunter's chicken it's another it's
another plate one uh which I don't think
is a compliment doesn't look great does
it um this is Hunter's chicken
traditionally this is chicken breast
with some bacon some cheese some
barbecue sauce I think bits of chicken
in here although I'm kind of struggling
to
see where
I think it's these like small bits
rather than like a chicken breast no
that's really bad beef goulash beef with
brown rice spinach carrots tomatoes and
smoked paprika a pepperoni pizza and
cheese
slice Army
pizza oh God that's so bad this has been
brutal I don't know what it is about
this food like yeah some things taste as
bad but things just just tasted okay but
I have a headache and my stomach doesn't
feel good I noticed there's a lot of
sodium in these so that might have
something to do with it tortillas came
with this one the Southwest style beef
and black beans with sauce again we have
very few breakfasts but this one is
mixed fruit which appears to be there's
some chunks in there so you got a bag of
mixed fruit on top of the mains and
breakfast options you also get a dessert
in a British ration pack the options we
got today included a chocolate brownie a
cinnamon cake a vanilla cake a chocolate
cake or an orange cake the US MREs have
an assortment of desserts looks all
right muffin tops cookies puddings cakes
a bun a toaster pastry cookies and
cobblers I'll try a couple of these I
want to try the brownie because it's
packaged differently to the others and
because I like brownie it looks a little
bit more cakey than brownish but uh
we'll see nuh that's so dry starting
down here getting maple muffin top or a
chocolate banana nut muffin top uh three
different types of cookies you get a
oatmeal chocolate chip cookie chocolate
chip cookie and oatmeal cookie that's
funny and actually I think about it
we've got patriotic sugar cookies could
be in the cookie category the packaging
was different so I separated them but
I'm curious kind a patriotic sugar
cookie looks like oh no nothing these
look like broken up Girl Scout cookies
is that a rocket what is that I don't
know what that is is you know what that
is oh like oh my God turn it around turn
it upside down ah it's a liberty torch
oh it's a bunch of different ones but
they're all broken up oh well these are
pretty good then I wanted to try one of
the cake options it's actually probably
the cinnamon that appeals to me the most
so I mean this looks
better it could be again slightly more
moist but it's got a pretty nice texture
to it it's definitely a cinnamon flavor
there in terms of like shelf stable
baked goods this is a much better effort
than the brownie was this is actually
like perfectly edible have an assortment
of pound cakes applesauce pound cake
lemon poppy seed pound cake vanilla
pound cake marble pound cake uh cinnamon
bun and a toaster pastry that just feels
completely destroyed in here so I don't
know what toas you're using on the field
but all right and last this package that
looks like all the other ones is a
cherry blueberry cobbler I think this
just be fine oh that's colorful but it
looks like a whole thing like
jelly every ration pack in the UK also
comes with four to five snack options
we've taken all the ones we got from
menus 1 to 10 and laid them out here
snacks our us MREs come with a lot of
snacks usually find three or four of
these in each M and various combinations
so here we have a mixed fruit snack
which is like a fruit puree in one of
these handy little pouches first of all
I mean how bright did these look just
compar to all the packs de with this
whole video like I'm looking at these I
almost want to turn the saturation down
peppermint candy rings and then you got
M&M's twizer nibs more M&M's Skittles
Skittles reac's pieces very nice thank
you there are a few different peanut
options on the menus in the UK starting
with barbecue peanuts some chili peanuts
and the classic salted peanuts dried
fruit dried
cranberries raisins and a trail mix that
has a nut r raisin mix for the trail
here we have cheddar cheese flavor
spread in the UK if you're having cheese
you'll have like cheese and crackers so
I feel like maybe this is supposed to be
enjoyed with some of these crackers down
this end down here three different types
of energy bars you can get I've never
heard of the brand First Strike not sure
if that is a brand that exists outside
the military we can get an apple
cinnamon chocolate or cran raspberry
energy bar oh jeez look at this
thing
not a bunch of
junk it tastes okay next we have a fruit
Flapjack Flapjack in the UK is a mixture
of Oats syrup butter and often raisins
which are kind of like packed together
to make a nice nutritious sweet treat
this is an oatmeal block I'm not really
sure what this is I'm actually going to
open this one just out of curiosity more
than anything looks like a sort of
shortbread biscuit on the
outside yeah somewhere between like a
digestive biscuit and like a Rusk which
for the
uninitiated is like I think an OTE
biscuit that's basically made for babies
I feel like he used to steal rusks from
my baby sister when she was little sorry
Annie trail mix granola nuts you got it
um packages of either dry roasted nuts
man they really suck this thing dry look
at that same with this one the uh smoked
almonds and jalapeno cashews recovery
trail mix with pretzels
granola and this trail mix has beef
jerky in it want to Mainline your jerky
US government has you covered beef
sticks here we have a sachet of peanut
butter we have three different types of
jam that we found we have apricot we
have Plum and we have strawberry jam
this is an exotic fruits nouar bar here
we have a sesame bar which is basically
just sesame seeds held together with
melted sugar apricot oat biscuits a
tropical fruit and nut mix as well as
just nuts and
just fruit cheese filed cracker
pepperoni
flavor uh cheese filed pretzel cheddar
flavor pretzel nuggets barbecue corn
nuggets barbecue flavored corn kernel so
like corn nuts right baked snack
crackers cheddar flavor and the protein
Puffs ring-shaped barbecue I feel like
if you get these ones you've done quite
well these sound fancy we have chocolate
orange mini cookies and coconut biscuit
bites sound like a more Gourmet approach
to uh a Russian P snack on to the breads
spreads we'll call it multi-grain bread
white wheat snack bread wheat snack
bread I mean how good are the shots we
have to get of these everything looks
the same and then this one Italian bread
blob blob got it okay great you have a
vegetable cracker or a regular cracker
what do you want to put on those breads
or crackers you got chunky peanut butter
peanut butter chocolate peanut spread
cheese spread cheese spread with
jalapenos cheese sprad with bacon here
we have cheese and oat biscuits which I
think are probably designed like I say
to be eaten with the cheesy spread next
up our biscuit Browns I wasn't sure what
a biscuit Brown was and after tasting it
I'm still kind of equally unsure it's
like a sort of brand like wheaty cracker
type thing for the fruit you got apple
jelly strawberry jam and know there's a
grape jelly from earlier I don't know
where it went but it looks exactly like
this package and finally we have a
cookies and cream bar that's not what I
was expecting at all when you hear
cookies and cream I'm right in thinking
that you expect Oreo right whereas this
is more like a like a rice krispy type
of treat doesn't smell of Oreo at all it
literally smells of like like a Rice
Krispy treat maybe dark chocolate
doesn't taste great either the US MREs
have an assortment of different drinks
both I guess regular temperature and
warm so the first thing I want to do
before we get into that is point out
that we have four different in the
middle here coffee drinks hot drinks you
want to as you have it this is a french
vanilla cappuccino and I want to make it
real quick we saw how we heated up the
the drinks before so here also comes
with a hot beverage bag pre- added the
water so now I'm going to go ahead
put tow in
here this looks all right mix it up a
little
bit I have
me
[Applause]
cappuccino it smells like when the VCR
gets really hot you watch like three
movies in a row now we're on to the
drink options which again I think you
get four of in a 24-hour British r pack
these all come in the form of powders
which you mix with water and then
consume they're also split into four
different categories we have just a
standard drink powder we have an energy
drink powder a fortified energy drink
powder and we have an isotonic drink
powder having quickly scanned the
ingredients of both of these I'm
actually not sure what the difference is
between say an energy drink powder and a
standard fruit flavor powder there's no
caffeine in the Energy powders for
example I think most of the energy is
coming from the sugar content in these
while that's cooking let's see what
other drinks we have
have we got orange lemon lime and grape
that's definitely not grape colored it
says grape on
here I think it tastes like grape but
also cuz it's blue I'm thinking blue
raspberry while my coffee is cooking
they also have different coffee flavors
I get a chocolate hazelnut protein drink
Irish cream cappuccino chocolate protein
drink regardless of the type of drink
powder that you're getting they do come
in a bunch of different flavor options
I'm not sure if any of these particular
appeal to me I'll try the Tutti Frutti
one I feel like of all of these sounds
pretty fun yeah I was really hoping that
the color would be like a bright blue or
pink or something but just
normal it's unlocking some kind of like
repressed alcohol memory I think I'm
fairly sure I've drunk a a cocktail to
the point of Oblivion that tasted pretty
much like this so this is my French
vanilla
coffee
oh yeah I'm not recognizing a lot of
these
words but yeah this is nice and the last
thing we have here are beverage based
powders uh so these had electrolytes in
them it's like energy drinks almost and
then these I think are just uh these
have lots of sugar so we have lemon lime
orange and chical punch and then this
little stick beverage based orange type
3 finally every ration pack in the UK
also contains a bag of common
[Applause]
items we'll start down this end where we
have some matches then we have some
water purification tablets I think there
are six of these in here actually and
according to this you can purify a liter
of water per tablet it's pretty good I
like that this is in the essential items
thing we have some hot sauce we have
some tissues as well as two alcohol free
hand wipes then you have two tea bags
two saet of instant coffee four saet of
beverage Whitener I think again this
might be something along the lines of
they can't legally call this powdered
milk but it is effectively a powdered
milk substitute and four sachets of
sugar our us MREs have these following
accessories first of all over here
you've seen it a few times this episode
the
heating thing the heating bags to heat
up your food and your drinks saw this
the whole time the spoon every M comes
with the spoon now as you notice I had a
difficult time kind of cutting into some
stuff and I thought why don't they have
anything like a knife in here of course
they have a knife they're soldiers they
have pocket knives uh they come with a
um concentrated beverage base this one
is cranberry grape over here is the
coffee zone for the most part bills
brewed freeze dried coffee you do add it
to hot or cold water 6 oz right here and
you have your choice of either Splenda
or sugar salt if you need more sodium on
your food this is a coffee creamer each
pack of accessory comes with two pieces
of gum these are water waterproof
matches spice up that food a little bit
a little bit of Tabasco little Tabasco
guy look is a little
guy right a moist tiet and regular
napkins in the US EMES were first
introduced in the 1980s and were
designed to be lightweight portable and
self-contained meals that didn't require
cooking or Refrigeration they were also
intended to provide the necessary
nutrition for soldiers in the field
early iterations of British ration packs
actually used cans it wasn't until the
1990s that these were replaced with
pouches each M typically contains around
1200 to 1300 calories with balanced
nutrition essential to supporting the
demands placed on soldiers during
military operations each m is said to
have approximately 170 G of
carbohydrates 45 g of protein and 50 g
of fat as we've said a British ration
pack is usually designed for 24 hours
worth of nutrition whereas it seems as
if the American ones are not we can
assume this because the average
nutritional value of an entire enire
British ration pack is somewhere between
3,800 and 4200 calories now here's a
chili meal from before we're going to go
through its specific nutrition now I
want to point out that the bag didn't
have anything on it so I am learning
about the nutrition of these in real
time the chili with the beans one
serving size all this is 260 calories
and this single serving of cornbread
with your chili also 260 calories your
vegetable cracker is going to be 170
calories and and your cheesy spread is
120 calories then the cheese filed
crackers the the pepperoni pizza flavor
240 calories for this one and if you
going to be sipping on your lemon lime
flavored nonf fruit juice juice that's
going to be 130 calories for the whole
beverage a grand total of this many
calories we've selected some items which
seem to match up roughly with what you'd
expect to find in a US M here we have
the chili con carne M we've got some
crackers with the cheese spread some
peanut butter and a fruit flavored drink
the total calories for these items comes
to
1,379 the FDA recommends that adults
consume around 75 to 90 milligram of
vitamin C per day just two of these
drink saet is more than enough vitamin C
for that intake we are not getting
scurvy anymore we learned our lessons
back in the Navy days although it's also
worth noting the amount of sugar that is
in one of these in a 45 G sachet of
mango and passion fruit drink you will
find 40.5 g of sugar that's 81% of your
daily recommended intake just in one of
these
let's take a look at the ingredients of
the chili con car in the UK beef red
kidney beans tomato puree water onion
red and green peppers wheat flour
calcium carbonate iron thamin and
nicotinamide modified May starch salt
spices spice extracts calcium carbonate
and smoke flavor the ingredients in here
are actually all pretty natural without
any real artificial preservatives our
eyebrows were raised when we saw
nicotinamide in the wheat flour
thankfully it's not some kind of nicotin
it's just another type of vitamin B3 AKA
nasin this chili with beans contains all
this uh looks like mostly normal stuff
until you get the bottom of the list
there ethylated mono diglycerides I have
no idea what that is I don't think I've
ever had that in food Wars before so uh
if someone in editing can go ahead and
say what it's used for these have a
minimum shelf life of 3 years depending
on storage conditions uh the storage
conditions for these MREs I'm assuming
were room temperature the whole time so
I'm feel feeling pretty confident these
are all uh not expired similarly ours
have a shelf life of around 3 years and
after that it's down to the temperature
at which they're stored for example this
chili was made in December 2021 and
apparently is shelf stable until around
2025 and how can these meals have such a
long shelf life you ask according to the
USDA MREs are shelf stable because they
have been commercially sterilized by
heat in a sealed container to destroy
bacteria that can make it unsafe or
spoil the food
like food in metal cans MREs can be kept
for a long time but not indefinitely the
shelf life of MREs and ration packs is
pretty directly related to the
temperature at which they're stored the
cooler the storage temperature the
longer they'll last rations in a desert
temperature might only last a few months
whereas rations at room temperature or
colder climates can be good up to 5
years we're filming this towards the end
of 2023 which means that our chili conar
for example is already around 2 years
old I've got to say I don't feel great
after eating them however I do think
that's probably more due to the quantity
that I've eaten rather than due to the
storage quality of these since 1981 the
US menu has changed about five times
improving the quality and the taste it
also has expanded the menu variety and
now includes vegetarian kosher and Hal
options there also aren't many changes
in the UK however there was a recent
controversial change chocolate bars were
taken away from British troops serving
in Iraq and Afghanistan because they
kept melting in the desert heat they
were replaced with a much less popular
Peanut Butter I can see how people would
be annoyed about that so you get five
matches as well as one of these little
striking
strips I broke it so oops it Daisy